hey 42 here have you ever gone to the
supermarket
hoping to just pop in for some eggs and
milk
only to emerge two hours later like a
contestant on supermarket sweep
with a bulging trolley full of frozen
fish microwave pizza
a decade supply of squirty cheese and
the discounted four sliced toaster
you didn't even know you wanted well it
turns out
you're not the only one most of us
vastly underestimate
how much we spend in the supermarket
because we tend not to realize
how often we go or just how much we
spend
when we're there the average uk shopper
makes
an incredible 221 trips to the
supermarket
every year and apparently our friends
across the pond
enjoy a trip around the supermarket just
as much as we do
because the average american spends over
60 hours per year buying groceries
last year supermarket sales topped 638
billion dollars in the us
with seattle residents coming in as the
biggest spenders
splashing out over 500 every month
on groceries so just how do
supermarkets convince us to part with so
much
of our hard-earned cash you might be
thinking it simply has something to do
with the fact that they mostly sell food
and drink
the kind of things those need to survive
and that's true but it isn't the whole
story
because over the years the marketing
tactics of supermarkets
have been carefully honed to the point
that modern stores
have evolved into near-perfect
money-making machines
like the retail equivalent of the
xenomorph
your local supermarket has been
meticulously designed to manipulate you
in ways you couldn't even imagine
every single feature of the shop has
been put there to do one
of three things get you into the store
keep you there for as long as possible
and
most importantly of all ensure you make
purchasing decisions
based on emotion rather than logic
let's start at the beginning what's the
first thing you do before you go into
the supermarket
unless you're just popping in for a
cheeky six-pack or a tesco meal deal
you're probably going to try and find a
basket or a trolley
and here's the first trick have you ever
walked into the supermarket to find just
one basket left
with somebody else's empty snickers
wrapper in it
well that's because supermarket staff
are deliberately told
to limit the number of baskets available
in order to try and get customers to
take a trolley instead
why because the bigger the carts the
more likely you are to try and
fill it according to business experts
martin lindstrom
doubling the size of the shopping
trolley lead shoppers to buy
40 percent more food which is probably
why
since they were first introduced in 1937
shopping trolleys have tripled in size
and
our waistlines have undergone a similar
rapid expansion
apparently we really are that easy to
manipulate
so you grab your trolley because you
can't find a basket and head through the
entrance of your
local supermarket at which point you
enter something called
the decompression zone that might sound
like the kind of place over enthusiastic
scuba divers go to ride out the bends
but it's actually just a large well-lit
area at the front of the supermarket
that you enter before getting into the
main store
the decompression zone is there to help
you transition from
regular you the person who has a job and
responsibilities and bills to pay
into capitalist you the ruthless
consumer who loves a family sized pack
of mint choc chip ice cream into the
trolley
just because they can you bloody
maverick you
essentially the decompression zone is
there to give you a chance to get used
to the store
before you're properly inside to become
accustomed to things like
the different lighting and floor
textures and to give you a chance to
slow down from the frantic pace of life
in the real
world for the most part high value
products are kept away from
decompression zones
as most shoppers won't notice them but
supermarkets like to chuck a bit of
subliminal messaging into the mix here
by offering a kind of fresh off the farm
experience
using natural imagery fresh scents
and bright colours to inspire a happy
and positive mental state in their
customers
after all would the shopping experience
start on such a good note if the first
things you saw were
spam dog food toilet cleaner and light
bulbs
once inside you'll most likely come
across the fresh produce section of the
supermarket
it's usually kept near the entrance to
make sure you associate the store with
fresh wholesome food and a common tactic
in europe and north america
is to make sure the fruit and veg is
regularly misted with water
you might assume this practice is there
to help keep the produce fresher for
longer
but in reality there are other more
nefarious reasons behind it
misting fruit and vegetables helps them
retain more water
which sounds like a good thing i'm sure
we can all agree that
nice plump melons look much more
appealing than tripled
dry ones until you realize most
supermarkets
charge you for this kind of stuff by
weight
regular misting can make some common
veggies up to 25
heavier than their non-misted
counterparts
meaning you're effectively buying a very
expensive bottle of water
alongside your savoy cabbage without
even realizing
it not only that but dousing fresh
produce in water
actually makes it spoil faster because
it creates the perfect breeding ground
for mold
so yeah stay away from those wet ass
peppers
supermarkets also seek to exploit your
psychology
in the way they're laid out most
shoppers tend to stick to the outside
perimeter of the shop
which is sometimes called the race track
which seems a bit of a stretch given
that instead of formula one cars packing
v8s
the racetrack is mostly populated by
granny's pushing squeaky trolleys
but there you go the race track tends to
be wider than the actual aisles
meaning it can accommodate more people
and of course allow for overtaking
grannies
because the race track is so busy
promotions and special offers are
normally placed at the ends of isles
as these are areas of higher visibility
in fact
we are so conditioned to expect bargains
in these locations
that customers are 30 percent more
likely to buy
items at the end of isles than in the
middle
the same goes for the reduced section
which stores used to sell off as much
food as possible before it expires
on the subject of expiry dates most are
actually quite misleading
and are used to some degree by some
supermarkets
to get you to throw out products and
replace them more often
so that yeah you guessed it you spend
more money
about 1.3 billion tons of food is wasted
around the world each year
that's about one-third of the total
amount of food
bought for human consumption globally
and plenty more than enough to feed the
700 million starving people here on
earth
something to think about the next time
you chuck out some milk based on a
pessimistic expiry date
instead of the good old-fashioned sniff
test supermarkets may
exploit the high foot traffic of the
race track but that doesn't mean they're
content to just let you wander around
the outside of the store and then leave
no they want you to walk down as many
aisles as possible
and to put as many oh so tempting
products within your reach as they can
whilst you're at it
which is why they deliberately place
very popular items
things like tea and coffee or in the
case of covet pasta and toilet roll
in the middle of isles but even once
they've got to you right where they want
you
walled in on all sides by hundreds even
thousands of products
they're still employing sneaky
techniques to bleed you for everything
you've got
the most expensive products are normally
put at shelves on eye level to make them
more obvious
whilst cheaper alternatives are put on
the top shelf out of reach
and items like kids cereals are normally
placed on lower shelves
so they'll grab the attention of the
little ones before mum has a chance to
fob them off with muesli
on the topic of kids cereals have you
ever noticed how
so many have cartoon characters on the
box like the cocoa pops monkey
frosty's tiger the lucky charms elf the
sugar puffs honey monster
and the cheerios bee that's because
research has shown
that if you make eye contact with a
character on a cereal box
you're more likely to feel connected to
the brand and will prefer it
over other choices in other words kids
don't just find these cartoon characters
friendly
they're genuinely making friends with
them which might sound cute
but is a little bit creepy when you
think about it
but can there be such a thing as too
much choice
according to a study carried out by
american psychologist sheena lienger
author of the best-selling book the art
of choosing
there can the average supermarket
contains 44
000 different items and enough variety
to give even the most decisive shopper a
bit of a headache
lienger wanted to see how all this
choice impacted shopper behavior
so she manipulated the number of
varieties of jam
available to shoppers and tracked how it
affected
what they purchased she found that when
six varieties were available
only 40 of shoppers stopped to browse
compared to 60 when 24 varieties were
available
so the more choice there is the more
likely people are to look
but that doesn't mean they actually buy
more
leaner found that choice is attractive
but
too much choice can actually negatively
impact sales
in the first scenario with six varieties
available
45 percent of those stopping to browse
ended up buying jam
whereas only two percent of people did
when their full
24 varieties were available the reason
for this discrepancy lies in the way our
brains are wired
the prefrontal cortex which is concerned
with working memory and decision making
amongst many other things is only
capable of handling around seven pieces
of information at any one time
any more and it quickly gets overwhelmed
and sort of just
panics and gives up basically making the
shopper abandon the task at hand
and move on to something less confusing
so
if you're ever feeling overwhelmed just
remember
at any one time thousands of people
around the world
are getting confused by jam
now there are ways you can support your
prefrontal cortex
for example by working things out with
pen and paper
but you're unlikely to start jotting
down the pros and cons of smoker's
strawberry jam
versus welch's raspberry jam in your
journal so in the context of a
supermarket that isn't too much help
a second option is to bypass the
prefrontal cortex altogether
and instead rely on gut instinct from an
evolutionary perspective our gut
instinct decision making process
is designed to cope with relatively
straightforward decisions like
whether or not to flee from a charging
woolly mammoth
in the slightly more complex world of
the supermarket
where woolly mammoths are rare our gut
instincts
are not so reliable there's simply too
much sensory information to process
bear in mind the average walmart
superstore is sixteen and a half
thousand square meters bigger than two
premier league football pictures
stuck together our brains simply aren't
designed to cope with so much stimulus
over such a large area one of the ways
our brains tries to cope is by
streamlining focus and choosing some
bits of information over others
generally speaking
a person can only read and understand
four to seven
words per second and so we're less
likely to make decisions in supermarkets
by reading
lengthy ingredient labels or the
detailed history
of a particular kind of cheese not that
it's necessarily easier to make
decisions by comparing price either
supermarkets deliberately complicate
things by showing mixed units
sometimes milk is listed by price per
pint
and sometimes price per liter either way
supermarkets are milking us
for all we're worth so if you can't use
words and numbers to make good choices
we have to rely on something much
simpler
what products actually look like studies
have shown that 93
of buyers make decisions based on the
visual appearance of products
and therefore manufacturers think
incredibly carefully about the shapes
and colours of their designs and
packaging
think about the rise of the quirky craft
beer bottle designs like
brewdog or bells which both use bright
colours and quirky illustrations to be
more eye-catching and memorable as well
as advertise their all-important hipster
credentials
color is hugely important in helping
brands shout at us from the shelves
in the uk purple is so synonymous with
cadbury's chocolate
bars the company has actually
trademarked their own specific
shade whilst coca-cola's red is
recognizable in virtually every country
in the world
in fact researchers have found that
people feel so passionately about
colours
they actually feel stronger emotions
when looking at chocolate packaging
than they do from tasting the chocolate
itself
the same goes for shape think about the
toblerone triangle
kitkat's two-fingered salute or
maltesers mighty spheres
these are iconic shapes that are just as
important to their brands
as the taste of their products okay so
thanks to the insidious brain hacking of
your local supermarket
you've run around the racetrack and
completed a circus of every aisle
filling your trolley to the brim with
things you didn't really want in the
process
your shop is nearly complete but you're
probably still looking for milk and eggs
because most supermarkets place them as
far apart as possible
in order to ensure you clock up a few
more miles around the store before you
leave
unless you really like to live life on
the wild side
the check house is the final hurdle of
any supermarket shop
and it's also the most dangerous because
this is where supermarkets place all the
things you know you shouldn't buy
but really really want to sweets
chocolate bars magazines chewing gum
and other impulse buys that you're more
likely to make when you're tired hungry
and probably a bit emotionally
vulnerable from all the subtle
brainwashing that's been going on during
your shop
the key for the checkout is a golden
window of opportunity for supermarkets
for two reasons firstly lining the
checkout with sweets has a similar
effect on children
as lining it with crack wood on a drug
addict
all children come pre-programmed with a
special skill
known as pester power and here is where
they deploy it with extreme prejudice
to nag their parents into submission the
second reason checkout traps are so
successful
is that people are more likely to make
unhealthy decisions
as they leave the supermarket because
their brains want a reward for all the
hard work they've been doing
getting thoroughly washed by the evil
supermarket overlords
according to brain scan experiments at
bangor university in wales
most people can make rational decisions
for about 40 minutes of shopping
but after that they stop being so
selective
and begin shopping emotionally and this
is when they accumulate
all the stuff they never actually
intended on buying
white chocolate cookies why not a packet
of haribo
sure i buy one get one free bag of
obscure walkers crisp flavors which
you're not even sure if you actually
like
who the hell even knows anymore not
content with their current level of
customer manipulation
supermarkets are always looking for ways
to get better at passing goods from our
money
cctv cameras may look like they're there
for our safety
and to stop sneaky shoplifters but
they're also there to track our behavior
and
movements so stores can shift promotions
and offers around
to make sure they get maximum exposure
similarly loyalty cards might seem like
a customer benefit
but they're actually designed to track
your purchases
something which will become all too
evident the next time you try shopping
online and find yourself bombarded with
targeted ads
for products you've bought in the
supermarket
the truth is there's no escaping the
psychological power of supermarkets
across the world we have been
indoctrinated by iceland
manipulated by morrisons coerced by
costco
tricked by trader joe's and accosted by
aldi
try as we might we will continue to love
little's mini pastries
and crave kroger's hallowed halls but
at least knowing a few of the
supermarket's dirty tricks
might stop us from bankrupting ourselves
every time we need to buy a loaf of
bread
thanks for watching you can get your
hands on my book stick a flag in it over
on amazon or on audible links to both in
the description below
thank you